immeuble hôpitaux bâtiments
administratifs en ukraine le kremlin ce
attaque délibérément aux populations
civiles comme cette école bombardée dans
l'est de l'ukraine ce samedi
pas plus tard qu'hier dans le village de
bil au gorille fca dans la région de
lougansk une bombe russe a tué 60
personnes des civils il se protéger des
bombardements dans le bâtiment d'une
école ordinaire qui a été attaqué par
une frappe aérienne russe le secrétaire
général des nations unies antonio goûter
res s'est dit horrifié par ce
bombardement
mais ce n'est pas la première fois que
la russie vise une école ukrainienne le
25 février cette école maternelle est
touché par une explosion des civils y
avaient trouvé refuge parmi les victimes
un enfant puis le 3 mars dans les rues
de tchernihiv alors qu'il faisait la
queue pour acheter du pain une phrase
bruce atteint des civils ukrainien
autres attaques sur des civils qui a
marqué les esprits le théâtre de mario
folle où un millier de personnes
s'étaient réfugiées le 16 mars le
théâtre est détruit par l'aviation russe
le dernier bilan officiel fait état de
600 morts parmi les sites civils visés
les hôpitaux d'abidjan l'om est à
maintenant vérifier 200 attaques sur des
établissements de santé en ukraine ce
depuis le début de la guerre ces
attaques doivent cesser les
établissements de santé ne doivent
jamais être pris pour cible et ce même à
target illustration de ce que beaucoup
appellent la stratégie de la terreur
le massacre de boudhha plus de 400 corps
ont été retrouvés selon un bilan
provisoire